yes I've already endorsed Barack Obama
the reason why I've endorsed him is I
think first is a character thing like i
said i think if you look at the issues
everybody wants all Americans to get
health insurance among John Edwards
Hillary Clinton and Barack Obama all of
them I think feel like we made a lot of
mistakes and foreign policy and want to
improve our standing in the world all of
them want to take care of our poor more
effectively and our working class I
think all those things are very
important but I think when I look at
Barack and how he's carried himself I
look at the things he's written over the
years especially dreams of my father his
first major book if I look at his
biography a look at the things he says
now during his speeches I feel like I'm
seeing someone who has true integrity
has a true sense of himself and is
comfortable with himself and I trust him
this is that simple I trust him because
of that it makes me believe that he will
do the right thing because a lot of this
a lot of the circumstances that are
going to happen to a president or
unpredictable like no one would have
predicted that George Bush would have
had to handle 911 for instance and
because things are unpredictable you
can't just rely on their specific issue
stances right now you have to somewhat
rely on the kind of judgment you think
they have is a person and the kind of
integrity they have and what their moral
compasses and I honestly believe when it
comes to that criteria
Barack is clearly the most qualified to
Professor I think this country is ready
for a black president I not because he's
black not because everyone's come to
some great racial understanding but
because he is who he is and because of
his character and because he is who he
is as an individual and what he stands
for him what he's and the kind of
campaign he has run I think America is
ready for Barack Obama to be President I
don't know if they would have been ready
for another black man to be President
but this black man I think they're ready
for him to be present